In this lesson, we are discussing basics, statistics and
machine learning methods that you can use to analyze your
data. Not only can we draw conclusions that are statistically
sound about existing data, we can also make predictions about
the data that we might collect in the future. During
this lesson, we have chosen to really zero in on
a couple of methods. Specifically Welsh's T-test and linear regression
with gradient descent, but as you can imagine, this is
just the tip of the iceberg. There are tons of
statistics and machine learning techniques out there. If you're interested, I
would really encourage you to go out there and read more
about those stats and machine learning. Now that you're familiar with
these statistics and machine learning techniques, you'll use them to
make predictions about subway ridership in New York and also to
draw some conclusions about the existing subway data that we have.
Once you have made these conclusions and predictions you might find
that you'd really love to communicate them to other people.
Be they your friends, or your teachers, or your family.
One of the most effective ways to do that is
through data visualization. That's what we'll cover in the next lesson.